as soon as they got my evidence it felt
like
they were like wow we've got a problem
here
and suddenly it felt like it went away
from the institutional and working with
the club
they tried to make it about individuals
and that's why unfortunately we've the
last couple of weeks some individuals
have had a really tough time but i
didn't present my evidence like that it
was never intended like that and that
was never the allegation but that's what
the club
the lawyers and the panel
in particular i've tried to do
i mean to make one thing very clear
[ __ ]
is not banter racism is not banter
and for a person of color i think
there's three people of color on that
panel and one of them
chief exec i think
he's associated with national asian
cricket council and ceo of
london tigers an award-winning charity
organization working with rugby and
football clubs
for him to come out and doing again an
article where he stands by the finding
that
[ __ ] was used as banter
it just shows the scale of the problem
we have
there's a report in the report those
mentions made of your your drinking
that you were a heavy drinker during
your time at yorkshire
what was your view of them linking your
claims of harassment to your drinking
well look i've been clear from the
offset i wasn't perfect
there's things i did the things i did i
felt i had to do to fit in and try and
achieve my dreams
um and i'm not proud of them it's
something i deeply regret
but it has no relation to racism
i should have never ever been treated
the way i got treated
and when i spoke i should have been
listened to
but yorkshire kind of critical but the
game as a whole
really has a problem uh in listening to
the victim and it's it's been
gaslighting it's been yet but
yeah but but there is no yet brought to
racism there is no two sides to a story
when it comes to racism
were you ever forced to drink alcohol
before you were 18 by other people at
the club and how do you view
the harassment you suffered for
undertaking uh answering the call for
prayer
look um i
my first intern
of drinking i actually got pinned down
at my local cricket club and red wine
got poured down my throat how old were
you 15 15 you're a muslim 15. 15 year
old
i got
literally
down my throat
the player
played for yorkshire played for
hampshire
and yeah it was quite a
experience i didn't touch
i didn't touch alcohol until about
around 2012
and
around that time i felt like i had to do
that to fit in
like i said i
i regret that massively um
but again i would like it has no
bearings on
the things that i was called uh and the
really around the loss of my son um
the sort of attitude of andrew gill the
coach
um saying to me
that i'm making it more than what it is
before the loss
after the loss
hardly ever anyone saying actually mate
are you all right is your wife alright
it was all about well he raised bullying
last year before he raises something big
let's get rid of him
and the harassment over the call to
prayer as well do you see
yeah look
obviously um i have me myself i don't
remember having that but i i know
certain other people
um
i've seen some another player fasting
for example and if he made a mistake
while fasting
from the strength and fitness condition
coach to the physio
to coaches and fellow players would be
blaming him for any mistakes he made as
opposed to actually understanding that
that's at yorkshire that's at yorkshire
yeah
okay
um tell us about kevin and steve what
those names signify in yorkshire cricket
well look steve um so i once i left the
club uh pajara joined the club um
and uh
jack brooks i think started it where he
didn't feel the need to call him by his
first name there is an interview with
chateshware where he said i'd prefer
them not to
but not only did jack
the coaches
everyone else the media yorkshire post
um the yorkshire website the cricket
yorkshire twitter page everyone called
him that commentators around the world
some high-profile people
it just shows again back to what the
institutional
feelings and how what that environment
showed people and how they could behave
so that was a steve point
kevin was something gary used uh to
describe everyone of color
in a very derogative manner whether that
be publicly
whether it be within the dress room
whether that be opposition this is
an open secret within the england
dressing room
this is anyone that's come across gary
would know that that's a phrase he used
to describe people of colour it was used
in a derogative manner
all the time
so you're saying that effort to be in
the england dressing room they use the
name kevin to signify people of african
caribbean origin is that correct
anyone of color anyone of color anyone
of color and is it true that there is an
english cricket as well named as black
dog kevin as an in joke yeah that is
true because gary and alex hales at the
time got really close to each other um
when they played for england together
and that's my understanding obviously i
wasn't present in that dressing room but
that's why i understand that um alex
went on to name his dog
kevin um because it was black
how do you view that
um well it's it's disgusting to be
honest um how much of a joke it was
as i said um
until right at the end i was in complete
denial as to what was going on it was
only around two back end of 2017 and
when i lost my son i went you know what
hold on a minute
i've seen other players do have family
tragedies and get support beyond measure
and i've just carried my son
from the hospital
to the graveyard and
how i'm getting treated here is not
right and
to me it became very clear that even
myself i'd been looking the other way
and there's a real problem here not just
yorkshire throughout the country
um
and i'm gonna be the one that's gonna
speak about this thank you